OCD is a mental condition in which a person
has unwanted, intrusive, and repetitive thoughts
that become obsessions.
These obsessions then make them do things
that relieve them from these thoughts, a behavior
known as a compulsion.
This is why it’s called Obsessive-Compulsive
Disorder.
OCD tends to develop most frequently in children
10–14 years of age with symptoms that range
across a wide spectrum.
Some just have repetitive thoughts, others
experience extreme obsessions that make living
a normal life difficult.
For many, it comes and goes in waves.
Symptoms of OCD are often grouped into four
factors: symmetry, forbidden thoughts, cleaning,
and hoarding.
Some might experience other symptoms, and
still others a mix of multiple factors.
Miko, Ann, Jane, and Joe each have their own
version of OCD.
Miko is obsessed with symmetry and he can
spend hours sorting books.
And whenever he enters his library, he has
to leave it the exact way that he came in
— backward.
Ann began having “forbidden” negative
thoughts after she lost her mom.
Ever since she’s constantly afraid that
others around her may die - including herself.
Her forbidden thoughts can strike at any time.
Her heart starts pounding, and a terrifying
image crosses her mind.
To make them go away, she starts biting her
nails until they bleed.
Jane is obsessed with cleanliness and gets
anxious when things appear dirty.
She washes her hands like 50 times a day.
And when she’s done, she washes the soap
too, because in her world everything is covered
in germs — especially the things she touches.
Joe is constantly thinking about losing things
and to relieve his anxiety he begins hoarding.
When leaving his house, he checks the lock
on the door again and again.
Then, 5 minutes later he starts wondering
if he’s closed the windows.
And so he returns — thinking he was so obsessed
about locking the door, that he might have
missed the windows.
So how come that in a group of people, just
some have OCD?
People with OCD are often born with a genetic
predisposition with about 1 in 4 having an
immediate family member with the disorder.
At some point in life, environmental factors,
such as childhood trauma, can initiate the
onset of OCD or exacerbate its intensity.
While the neurobiological origins are still
being studied, brain areas regulating thought
processing may be disrupted in minds with
the disorder.
As a result, their thoughts can't shift properly,
and instead get stuck, repeated, and lead
to a loss of control.
Someone who has to check if they locked the
door over and over again, has the thought
“Did I lock?” repeating endlessly without
being resolved.
While obsessions just seem to appear in one’s
head, compulsions are learned responses that
help reduce the anxiety associated with intrusive
thoughts.
So if Jane experiences an ever-present fear
of germs, she reduces her anxiety by washing
her hands.
Because this ritual temporarily offers relief,
the probability that she will do it again
is increased.
Once the OCD Cycle is established, obsessions
lead to anxiety which triggers the compulsion
that brings the relief — and then it starts
again.
As a result, compulsive behavior not only
persists but actually becomes excessive — often
with negative consequences and makes living
a normal life impossible.
When you begin having OCD you often aren't
aware of it and, as a result, some of the
terrible thoughts in your brain lead you to
believe that you are a bad person.
This is why it's important to seek professional
help to understand and eventually "quiet the
brain”.
Treatment of OCD includes:
Cognitive behavioral therapy: to overcome
intrusive thoughts by not indulging in any
compulsions
Rumination: focused exposure with response
prevention that focuses on obsessions
Medication
Or nicknaming to relabel, reattribute, refocus,
and revalue your thoughts
What about you?
Have you ever experienced obsessive thoughts?
And if so, what kind of compulsions did you
turn to?
Please share your insights and strategies
for dealing with your mental monster in the
comments below!
If you found this helpful, check
out our other videos and subscribe.
If you want to support our work,
join us on patreon.com/sprouts.
For more information and additional
contents, visit sproutsschools.com